la quinzaine des réalisateurs est un
concours parallèle au festival de cannes
la réalisatrice alice vino cours est
venu y présenter son dernier film revoir
paris l'histoire de millas joué par
virginie efira prise dans un attentat
terroriste
le film suit son cheminement elle ne se
souvient pas de tous les événements et
mène son enquête pour se rappeler et se
reconstruire pour ce film la
réalisatrice s'est inspiré du témoignage
de son petit frère parce que mon petit
frère était dans le bataclan il a
survécu évidemment le film ne parle pas
du bataclan un attentat imaginaire mais
c'est vraiment oui un voilà j'avais
envie de faire un film de résilience est
un film de reconstruction sur cette
question en fait un monstre en fait une
communauté extrêmement soudée de
victimes qui essayent de reconstruire de
se reconstruire ensemble après les
événements ce qui m'a intéressé c'est
pas l'événement de l'attentât en soi
mais c'est les traces qu'elle ait laissé
chez les victimes qui se rappellent que
de fragments fait un film conclut déjà
voir les festivaliers à cannes le
tournage a été bouclé en décembre et le
montage a été finalisé un jour seulement
avant le début du festival et la salle a
été plutôt conquise écoutez je trouve
que c'est intéressant parce que ça parle
de la mémoire traumatique ça me parait
exactement des événements des faits et
sa part de la mémoire traumatique
monstre construire pas ça comment on
reconstruit les événements qu'on a vécu
est qu'on a oublié de manière volontaire
ou non c'est un film bouleversant que je
trouve qu'ils laissent pas indifférent
bien sûr qui remue beaucoup
pour les autres il faudra attendre
encore un peu avant de voir le film sur
les écrans la date de sortie n'a pas
encore été dévoilé mais ça sera d'ici la
fin de l'année